what is the difference between a linear  regression and a logistic regression a  regression analysis is a method for  modeling relationships between variables  it makes it possible to inferior or  predict a variable based on one or more  other variables the variable we want to  infer or predict is called the dependent  variable or Criterion the variables we  use for prediction are called  independent variables or predictors in a  linear regression the dependent variable  is a metric variable for example salary  or electricity consumption in a logistic  regression the dependent variable is a  dichotomous variable dichotomous  variables are variables with only two  values for example whether a disease is  present or not so with the help of a  logistic regression we can determine  what has an influence on whether a  certain disease is present or not we  could study the influence of age gender  and smoking status on that particular  disease